in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
dr. Leo you are chief physician of the
department of psychotherapy and
psychosomatics medicine thanks for
inviting me into your clinic this is a
clinic and you're treating patients with
anorexia and eating disorders and we are
not in a normal hospital room here we're
in a kitchen twice that yeah we are in a
kitchen and in fact we try to bring our
patients into normal areas of living
from right from the beginning of the
therapy instead of only sitting with
them in psychotherapy sessions or on the
ward or in medical conditions we try to
share as much as we can normal life with
them and then that implies that we go to
the kitchen we bake together we cook and
try to be bring as much as we can normal
eating habits back to the patients so if
you would put me into a kitchen and do
some cooking with me I would be
absolutely happy and satisfied but with
those patients was with eating disorders
it might be a totally different story
yes it's more complicated what we try is
that we are very empathic with these
patients we try to select what can they
eat at a special stage of a therapy at
the beginning it will be very restricted
and we try to enlarge and more and more
the spectrum of things which we can eat
and prepare together so how young are
you the patient's which are you
suffering from eating disorders like
anorexia well we know that due to an
earlier onset of puberty and patients
get younger and younger we speak now of
girth of about ten years of age we're
eating disorders start and that is
because of the influence of social media
casting shows for example which convey
an image of the perfect thin body and at
the same time we have hormonal reasons
like the onset of puberty is earlier and
we know that an early onset of puberty
in girls is a risk factor for developing
eating disorders but anorexia is not
only but good about get
very very thin and it's really disease
and it affects the body oh yes we know
that the whole organ system is affected
by anorexia we know that the heart can
suffer we know that electrolytes become
dis balanced and that is related to
rhythm abnormalities we know that the
kidney function is affected we know that
osteoporosis affects most of the
anorexia patients and we even know from
fMRI studies that the gray matter of the
brain decreases so if the body gets sick
and do the patients usually recognize
that they are sick that this is a
disease that you need to get treated or
do you need to persuade them we need to
appreciate them that's the main issue of
the first step of getting them into
therapy most of the patients are brought
by their parents the insight into the
disease is not there they it's a feature
of the illness that the body image is
distorted they conceptualize themselves
as being too thick even or too fat and
we can see that in video studies that
the silhouette of the body for example
is conceptualized as being too too large
or extended some experts say that and
Alexia is not even a real disease what's
your opinion that I agree i think it's a
lifestyle habit it's um being vegetarian
or vegan is a very hip method of
bringing out what you think about our
civilization society in a way a cultural
thing it's a cultural thing we have it
in big metropole like Berlin or Tel Aviv
or New York and we want to avoid meat or
egg products or milk or whatever and we
try to convey a certain attitude of our
life but but is it very difficult to say
that some condition is a disease or not
but not just with orthorexia vet but
take anorexia or other eating disorders
instance well it's a very clear-cut
definition we have the body mass index
which gives us an idea and we have a
clear-cut definition of the body mass
index being below 17.5 being the
criterion for underweight that said if
the body itself is healthy and that you
don't have anything like a malnutrition
or bowel disease so you need the
psychological factor as well oh yes of
course we need to have a very good
medical investigation we need to do a
laboratory or maybe even a gastroscopy
or coalesce copy and we need to see if
there's any bowel disease or any other
for example gluten sensitivity or other
things if some of our viewers say for
instance I've got a daughter and the
daughters getting slimmer and slimmer
and I'm very very afraid that she
suffers from anorexia and what should
they do they should bring her to a
general practitioner and he should do a
very thorough medical examination
including a blood draw and an ECG and
then when the diagnosis of anorexia gets
more and more sure he should go bring
her to a to a specialist appt
psychotherapist or a doctor specializing
psychosomatic medicine so like in your
clinic here and and if you treat
patients with eating disorders or what
do you do I mean we hear it in some kind
of an art room so it's for hot therapy
you see there a lot of colors here for
paintings so why does this help the
patients well what we try is to to bring
the patient in our boat we are in a we
try to become a partner of the patient
instead of the treating or doctor we try
to be on one level with the patient
because the patient's themselves they
don't see themselves as being sick it's
often the doctor or the parents which
say oh you are too thin but the
patient's themselves they have a
distorted body image and don't see what
they do what harm they do to their
bodies so what we tried
do like for example here is am pained
with the patients we cook with the
patients we make music with the patients
so to enlarge in the therapeutic room
and to have some fun together and also
get more and more obstacle therapy
focuses into the picture and if you try
to treat the underlying psychological
disorder is the body itself getting
better say for the organs to do they
recover oh yes we can see that for
example with MRI studies we see a
thinning of the gray matter in anorexia
and what we also see which is very very
nice to see is that the gray matter
comes back to its normal range within
three months of therapy for example with
weight restoration the brain substance
increases again good to know thanks dr.
vivo for inviting us into your clinic
thank you so much
you
you